uh welcome to the afternoon session I
guess the plan for today is to have like
it's about two talks a break then
another talk and then like
a reception and a poster session uh
which will happen simultaneously I mean
the reception of the poster session will
happen on the second floor
like at the time when the schedule says
uh just one thing uh like
worse to the second floor are gonna lock
at 5 p.m so like we'll need to like
open them for each other or something
anyway so
at the first talk is uh bengalob
es
uh
and they also with a hybrid talk hybrid
all right shall I start yes thank you so
first um I'll I think I'll say this
again later but I Alex
all right so I'm super grateful to be
working with the whole team but Alex in
particular has done just an amazing
amount of work to make this happen and
so I'm super grateful to him for uh
involving
me and uh for uh the opportunity speaker
uh so this has worked with
um work on pass through and Market power
a principal component approach with
galioti goyal palamas and umer tamus who
is here
um
and let me so this is a project about
differentiated oligopoly and I'm going
to do something a little unusual and
just start with one column of model
because it'll be easier
to do that to explain exactly what I
mean by the words differentiated
logopoly before I tell you what we do
with it
so there are this is a game a static
game among n players the players are
called firms
there's also going to be a
representative consumer
so each firm is identified with a single
good that it produces
and the simultaneous move game is that
firm simultaneously announced prices
each price is its own good which leads
to a vector P of everyone's prices
and then the consumer
is going to choose seeing those prices
the consumer is going to decide
um how much to eat the representative
household is going to decide how much to
eat of each good
at these prices
and then the consumer has a
utility function I guess this is the one
risk of the model on the first slide
but it's going to be it's going to
persist for a while so the for the
consumer is going to see these prices
that the firms have announced and is
going to decide how much to eat of each
firm's good
so
the consumer's utility function is
quasi-linear in in money over here and
it's just the value
for eating the various Goods
which in here we're going to be not
impose many assumptions for now at least
and say this is just a general a concave
continuous function
um
let's say continuously differentiable
um
and so
that's going to determine the consumer's
Choice here maximizing this utility
function with these prices is going to
determine the quantities of all Goods
that are purchased which is what these
firms care about when they're setting
their prices and the way the firms care
about it is that they're going to
receive profits equal to the quantity of
their good that the
uh consumer chose to buy times their
unit profit which is price minus a
constant marginal cost I don't really
need constant marginal cost but I will
uh assume it to keep things uh a bit
simpler
so for those who walked in late the only
I think the only important thing you
didn't hear is that at this stage before
anything else happens firms
simultaneously decide how each is going
to price its own good and each firm has
a proprietary right to produce good eye
so for my produces good I chooses the
price for that and then the consumer
eats and then the consumer gets this
payoff and the firms get these profits
any questions
uh this is this is a mistake so I would
write minus M here but here I even know
how much money the consumer spent which
is which is just P dot Q that's the
amount that it costs to buy these
different Goods yeah so I should really
just say this there should be no Emperor
it should be cfq thank you
other questions
so that's a differentiated that's a very
simple kind of canonical differentiated
oligopoly pricing game
and you can see pretty quickly from this
setup that
there's going to be fairly Rich
strategic interactions here because when
I change my price and therefore the
amount of my stuff that the consumer
eats it changes your demand curve so my
price matters for your pricing problem
so that makes these firms strategically
entangled
now we we know that this outcome there's
going to be interesting normative
questions here because
this kind of game is not going to lead
to efficient outcomes it wouldn't be
efficient if they were independent
monopolists each selling their own thing
and that's not really going to change
when their demands get entangled
these Market power effects and their
normative implications have been of
great interest to a recent so several
recent applied literature so for example
bakayan farhi showed that these kinds of
Market that market power distortions
make a big difference to aggregate GDP
if you want in a disaggregated rich
macro model
verstein and all co-authors show that
market power effects and varying wedges
or distortions over time make a big
difference to the analysis of
macroeconomic Time series
and then Pellegrino in a recent paper
uses a calibrated version of this style
of model
uh calibrating it to the whole U.S
retail Market to show that market power
distortions are a big deal eat up a lot
of the you know have a 20 welfare cost
to the US consumer or something so
applied people are interested in these
uh differentiated oligopoly type of
problems and what we want to do here is
do a
fairly humble I think microeconomic
exercise which is just the comparative
Statics of this differentiated oligopoly
so I'm going to specify an exogenous
uh
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
introduce a dummy parameter C which I
just used to move around the economy
think of it as starting as at zero I'm
going to specify
costs exogenously as a function of C so
this just gives me a way of defining a
movement of the exogenous parameters
which are the costs and then for any
other variable in the model typically
the endogenous ones I'm going to write x
dot just to say how that thing moves as
I move around this exotic you know when
I move around the cost exogenously
everything else is going to react and x
dot tells me how X reacts where X is
price quantity welfare whatever you
might be interested in
and a particular
object of interest for us is going to be
pass-throughs which is how a given
change in costs affects equilibrium
prices so so price pass-through is how
much a change in cost affects prices
welfare is how much it affects welfare
and what we're going to offer is a
principal component perspective on past
dues which is going to give us a new way
of writing out the comparative Statics
and saying which cost shocks matter most
in a sense for uh price and Welfare
volatility that's one thing we can do
that's kind of a physics exercise and
maybe more in a stack on top of that
will be a policy exercise which is if
you so this uses an idea going back to
Marshall that you can use small taxes to
shine a light on the distortions in your
economy you can understand the
distortions in your economy by asking
what's the first little unit if I had a
little unit of tax power and subsidy
power to try to remedy it you know
what's the first unit of intervention I
would do that kind of tells you where
the distortions in your Market are and
so we're going to study a stylized
problem of that type in order to uh
say what the distortions are in these
entangled CIS oligopoly systems and
we'll find that the principal component
analysis is a useful way to look at it
so that's the 10 000 feet overview and
now I want to tell you what we actually
do
um
we're going to fix we're going to assume
existence of it's not hard to guarantee
it we're going to assume existence of an
interior pure strategy National
equilibrium in prices
and we're going to look at it and then
we're going to study how Stuff moves
around by just basically differentiating
the first order conditions right so
we're going to we're going to look
locally at how this particular
equilibrium of the game moves around as
we perturb the costs so firms first
order conditions I I have re I've just
written them here they're not so
important but I thought it would be
um so this is when you just take firm
eyes uh profit and you differentiated it
in its control variable which is its
price and I should say here the
subscript like Qi is just
firm ice quantity it's not a derivative
okay so the only derivative here is this
thing
um and of course you you know the queue
is induced from the demands from the
consumers uh demand Behavior the
consumers maximizing something picks a
queue but once we have this queue we can
forget about everything underlying it
and just say that's the demand function
as a function of prices
so that's the consumer's first order
condition and now we're going to make a
gigantic assumption I'm going to assume
that in some neighborhood for for all
costs uh or let's let's say for all
prices in some neighborhood of where we
start the demand function is exactly a
linear function
so this is a terrible assumption it's
not true for example but uh
it turns out that a lot of the forces I
want to tell you about already appear in
this case and we've recently and now I
feel less bad about this whole thing
because in the last couple of weeks
we've managed to understand uh
everything without that assumption and
so it's not so important
um I think we can everything I'm going
to tell you has a suitable analog
without it but I'm going to be able to
tell you things more succinctly in this
case
um and
with this Assumption of linearity I'm
going to be able to Define sort of
something that's sufficient for
something a very important object that's
going to kind of play the starring role
in The Talk which is this demand
derivative Matrix
which is just the derivative well it's
the derivative of firm I's cost in firm
J's price
at
some some piece so it's the same it's
written it's the same thing that's
written up there and because I can
measure the goods that the firms are
selling in leaders or ounces
I can assume that the own price demand
effect is minus one that's just the
normalization of the of the quantity
measurements so that that I can get for
free and I am going to make that
normalization and after making that
normalization I can write down
the by implicitly differentiating this
these first order conditions in the
perturbation that I am interested in I'm
going to be able to write down the a
formula describing how the prices change
as the costs are exogenously perturbed
right and so this formula is also worth
writing down so P dot is going to be
equal to I minus D inverse
it's not
so that so that's the um
it's a d where D is minus one in
diagonal and then this Matrix happens to
have two on the diagonals
right I mean if D has minus one on the
diagonal this Matrix has twos on the
diagonal
so at some level maybe you could say we
could we should stop here
because I was interested in the
comparative Statics of the system
here they are I can write the price
effects as a function of the cost
perturbation
and in this room people
have a good bit of understanding of this
what that thing means
so maybe we can stop but I think if we
stopped here
there would be Insight left on the table
about what is going on with these costs
what how the cost perturbations
translate into
outcomes and
I want to convince you of that in the
rest of the talk I can just show you
what I mean by saying this is that we
can do better than just writing the
answer like this so let me try
especially for the tax policy kind of
question
let's try to let's try to say more
let's try to extract more insight out of
this formula
um so let me remind you but on the way
there let me just remind you of basic
intuitions that you already have about
price pass-through
um so price passthrough says if your
local bagel place has their marginal
cost of a bagel increase by
um 10 cents how much does your price
change right so often in intermediate
micro we solve a basic
um Monopoly with linear demand example
and we there's a slow when you solve
that problem you get a slope in your
answer which is a half and that's that's
the upshot of that is that
um the price pass through is
um a half
so if you have a little cost shock it's
going to translate The Firm if you're if
the bagels are become 10 cents more
expensive to the firm that's going to be
five cents more expensive for you and
the firm is going to eat the other five
cents out of its
the other five cent loss out of its
profit
right now it's opposite right it's now
it's their costs are rising
oh you're saying it goes up by more than
one or what are you saying something
the cost of food for the restaurant is
not foreign
foreign
[Music]
Market imagine two bagel stores that you
know face the same exact marginal cost
then uh one will become 101 says that
you have price equals marginal cost in
that case the passengers won
um now as we've seen in the formula that
we've already seen in a multi-firm
oligopoly passed through isn't a number
it's a matrix right every when when any
cost Changes Everything changes so and
so but this gives us some intuitions to
grab onto which we're going to be coming
back to
but now I can tell you the core
uh thought I guess of the whole talk
which is that we're going to switch
we're going to look at the whole
business in a different basis which is
which is a basis you choose based on the
demand Matrix itself so
this is where the representative
consumer assumption actually somewhat
matters
the fact that there's one representative
consumer determining all the demands
means that the demand Matrix that I
defined as a symmetric matrix it's very
closely related to the hessure so the
passion of this representative household
and so
um because D is a symmetric you can find
a basis of eigenvectors
uh that you can find the basis of
eigenvectors of that Matrix for the
whole space and these are orthonormal so
I can I can define a matrix U whose
columns are all eigenvectors of d
ordered in some way we'll talk about
later
um each of so each of these used is an
eigenvector of d
and jointly these form an orthonormal
basis for the whole Space if you have 17
firms for R17 okay
and how it the first thing that I'm
going to do with this is for any Vector
you have in mind for example the vector
of quantities I can rewrite it by
pre-multiplying by U transpose I can
transform it into this new basis of
these eigenvectors so in fact I'm often
going to talk about the vectors as
bundles of goods so you can think of
each of these columns if you're thinking
in good space you can think of this as a
bundle of goods and this is another
bundle of goods maybe with negative
entries so rather than saying
Christian's firm produces one and mats
firm produces two I can say the
production of the economy is one unit of
the first eigen bundle of the first
eigenvector and minus two units of the
second eigenbundle that's an equally
good way because these U's span the
whole space I can describe any
consumption outcome in that way
um and I'm going to be able to do the
same thing for prices I can in fact talk
about the price of the first eigen
bundle that just means also transforming
the prices into this new basis so I'm
going to be able to talk about a cost
shock to the first eigen bundler the
second eigen bundle or a combination
and having set that up
I can tell you like the reason we're
doing we're doing all this
which is which
is that we can make this we can State
this result
it's really a piece of bookkeeping it
says that once you've changed the basis
in this way you can write the effect on
the elf on the price of the elf bundle
you can write that effect
um
as just a constant times the shock to
the else cost
in this new basis so let me say it like
this if you have a cost shock that only
affects the first eigenvega crosstalk
that's parallel to the first eigenvector
crosstalk like this then I can tell you
exactly how it's going to affect the
prices it's going to affect the prices
exactly in that in that direction in in
the eigen basis so if the cost shock is
you know one zero zero zero
uh the price response is going to be
Lambda L zero zero zero zero so even
though in the original basis when I when
I change a means cost it affects
everybody's price because of all these
spillovers and interactions and this new
basis it's just going to feed through in
that one in that same Dimension and
there's going to be no cross effects of
any kind
um and moreover this price pass through
this coefficient Lambda which I call the
price pass-through is just some formula
that I have written up there of the
corresponding eigenvalue so the first
eigenvector had an eigenvalue
here and just some you know simple
transformation of it tells me the price
pass-throughs
so that's so that that tells me so you
know
um I'll say more about this but let me
just is the I hope the the math is clear
vectors and maybe you have to do
actually if the price is there but it's
a direction that the cost is there so if
I yeah if I didn't have symmetry which
which I could lose for example by not
having a representative consumer I would
have to do you the the way we're going
to extend the same thing that we do is
by using the singular value
decomposition
have different different bases on the
for the costs and the prices
um okay so I'm going to tell you I'm
going to complete this slide but before
that I need to define the thing which I
haven't defined so beyond the price
implications I already anticipated that
we're going to be interested in the
welfare implications of a cost chunk and
so I need to tell you
what I mean by welfare I'm going to make
a very economical definition of welfare
which is just a total Surplus metric so
remember the consumer had this payoff
the value of the goods minus the money
the household pays for the wings and the
producers make these profits you know
these are the unit profits so it's the
dot product of each firm's unit profit
times the quantities they sell and so
um welfare is the sum of those you can
think of it you know if you want a very
concrete foundation think of the firms
the consumer being a price taker when
she shops but then at the end of the day
all firm profits are ultimately rebated
back to the consumer in the numerator so
the household ends up eating that and
being happy to you know the profits in
the economy are also valuable ultimately
to the consumer
um you could also study incidentally for
you know since we had some uh socialism
over here we uh we can study just we can
do all of the exercises I'm going to
talk about just caring about consumer
surplus uh that would be fine too and
I'm just we you know I think economists
first instinct is to use this metric so
I'm going to tell you all the results
for total Surplus
um
so uh coming back to the result that I
had already put up most of the only
thing I'm adding to it now is this
welfare formula so if I'm interested in
how total Surplus is going to be
affected by this cost shock I can write
it as this formula which sums across the
different eigenvectors okay it's written
in the eigen in the eigen language
in the trans in the new basis that I've
transformed into so let's read this
formula for welfare it sums across these
eigen these Dimensions
um of the eigen of the these
eigenvectors
this I'll read from the end the Q at the
end here says that for a bundle that the
consumer is eating more of obviously it
matters more what happens to it so uh
when a bundle that is eaten in a large
quantity will have a big welfare impact
and there's a minus here because when
costs go up nobody likes that everybody
does worse when Costco have to eat less
stuff so quantity matters but what's
maybe more what's maybe more interesting
is that and of course the size of the
shock matter is C Dot and then the
coefficient mu is what we call a welfare
pass-through it's a number that says you
know
once you account for the
proportionalities that I just mentioned
how important is this bundle and it
turns out that the welfare pass-throughs
so let me this is maybe the last thing
I'll write up here the lambdas are the
price pass-throughs and the
Muse are the welfare pass-throughs
and it happens to be that they're
ranked oppositely to each other
so
Lambda is price passed through
1 over 1 minus
back from
minus the eigenvalue and mu is the
welfare pass through
it's 1 minus the price pass through so
I'll talk more about that's going to
make more sense I'm going to give some
intuition for that but the punch line is
that we can write both the price and the
welfare effects in a very succinct form
and if you think back to not doing this
transformation if you just wanted to do
this in the original basis you could
nobody would stop you but for the
welfare exercise you would have this
quadratic form thingy where you would
have to worry about all the cross
effects in like when my cost is
perturbed it changes your price that
changes welfare in the in you know so
you have to worry about all these these
cross effects when the system is
diagonalized you can somehow think of it
as decoupled and look at it as welfare
across as if independent pieces and
that's
has its it has its pluses of course how
good it is depends on how well we can
interpret it
so uh
because this is a short talk I'm not
going to be able to show you all of the
payoffs go ahead yeah I have a fun
question so yeah you started by saying
assume you have it in the United States
yeah and now you're saying oh so then it
decomposes nicely into eigen values yeah
so then I have to go back to the
original assumption how do we do this
that has nothing to do with linearity in
in the end what what the linearity was
used to simplify the exact form of this
implicit derivative but if your system
is differentiable there's going to be
some so differentiability is a real
assumption and that's and I don't think
that's but then you will have linearity
in a very small
yeah you could worry about the second
order first I mean let's put it like
this if you haven't understood the
system's first derivatives it's now time
to talk about the second derivatives yet
so it's not I mean yes comparative
Statics you can always ask about other
about further effects but it's not a
reason not to study the first ones I
guess our next point is you will have
something like the Hessian instead of
feedback it's yeah so if you wanted the
way I mean yeah the way the macro
yeah so you could right this is
absolutely true that this that the every
the derivatives can only tell you about
small perturbations and if you wanted to
understand further effects you'd need to
write down further derivatives and uh as
as actually in macro in macroeconomics
with different economic assumptions
people
um have done
um but
um
yeah right so I completely agree with
that
I'm sorry go ahead okay so
um in reality sort of price shops might
actually appear on a difference
because everybody has more money and is
less price sensitive and so uh but but
in reality probably it's actually not
some external cost where God changes the
cost it's probably either that the
demand changes consumers might be less
price sensitive or that the supply side
changes it's more costly to actually get
enough transport or whatever
and then all of this becomes more
complicated yeah absolutely so it
doesn't that helps me make an important
so the means point is that this is
fundamentally A first order uh it really
you have to you know it's a first order
exercise about the first derivatives the
and Christian's point is that it's
basically a partial equilibrium
supply-driven analysis here the cost
shocks and the shocks I'm studying come
from crosstalk's newest exogenous and in
a bigger economy they would be linked
everything would be the economy would
have all these interactions that are
basically being killed you know it's a
very it's an economy killing all those
interesting macro effects so this is
really a microeconomics paper about a
differentiated organ which takes the
market that this is about as sort of a
little decoupled piece of the economy
and
um the tradition I guess is to
understand those partial equilibrium
pieces and then integrate them into a
ritual macroeconomic model so those I I
agree with you and I knew those as a
kind of an um it's not orthogonal but
it's second it will be stacked on top of
this kind of number I was wondering sort
of concerning my previous questions
maybe if for example prices go up due to
Consumer Demand right then maybe
actually it is true that I'm willing to
pay more for my Vegas at the shop but
maybe the bagel shop is not willing to
pay that much more to this provider
and therefore the the science could be
the answer by wrong yeah yeah I think I
think generally equilibrium effects
could change all the signs absolutely
hope is going to help you out with an
example which is in what I might do in
my econ we call it 205. is you introduce
a subsidy so for some reason the
government is interested is interested
in subsidizing one of these Goods so
it's not a cost shock it's it's sort of
a tax or a subsidy on a particular good
and then you're going to want to know
you sort of do these exercises of how
that passes through to a particular
Market to that particular Market but
what you're able to do here show how
it's going to pass through through the
to the whole the whole exactly thank you
yeah so I'm going to yeah and in fact
that's where I'm hoping to get to this
little tax exercise so
um let me let me push on in the interest
of time so I I because I'm you know I
don't have enough time to tell you about
everything properly I'm going to give
you sorry about this article but I'll
I'm going to give you a big overview of
everything we can do with this framework
and then tell you as much of it the
detail as I have time so first there's
this free parametrization gives us a new
way of looking at the mechanics
so you can look at basically if you're a
financial analyst without with data
about
the theory of the volatility of costs
you think there's going to be commodity
price changes and they're going to
affect these firms uh pricing you can
try to understand just the physics of
how volatility and exogenous parameters
translates into volatility in outcomes
and that's obviously going to be shaped
by the tendency of the system to respond
in a particular way given by the
economics of the solid album so it turns
out the maximum and minimum volatility
that can be caused by external shocks
can be described in terms of the
eigenvalues I've told you about
um the main the main exercise in the
paper is a tax design exercise where
we're going to set up Rachel's exercise
of small Peruvian taxation I get to
subsidize some production and collect
that money by taxing some some other
production and it's going to turn out
that Express that I can and I hope to
tell you this in some in some form at
least give you a taste of it that the
principal component basis gives us a
much more legible way of expressing that
answer and the the value of Taxation
power then you could do without doing
this transformation and finally and
maybe most in some way most relevantly
to this audience or most in the spirit
of the Simon's link between Applied
Mathematics and these applied subjects
as you as you know in the recent
literature on
um
you know spectral approximation and the
theory of big matrices there's beautiful
results about how what you can recover
about a matrix with noisy observations
of it that's done a lot in all sorts of
machine learning and data science
applications and statistics and so
um
it turns out that because those results
like to do the principal component
decomposition anyway we can say things
about what you can recover what aspects
of the price response of the system you
can recover even though you have really
crappy measurement of a lot of the
details of the system like a lot of the
Matrix entries in the D Matrix you might
know with enormous noise and that should
be troubling right the econometricians
can't really estimate these amine was
complaining that it might not be linear
but even when you assume it's linear
it's very hard to recover you know those
kind of cross effects in D so when you
measure D with a lot of noise what can
you do looking at this this way shows us
that it's as far as understanding the
economic relationships it's not hopeless
you can actually recover some aspects of
this stuff despite very noisy
observation and so that's the big
overview let me now try to tell you um
well I will I will tell you but I will
first put up this
incredible thing I saw yesterday
uh
so rather than using
um quantum mechanics to better
understand the complexities of people's
style Minds we're going to use quantum
mechanics to understand this
differentiated oligopoly
foreign
okay so uh let me skip I have an
illustration of of it but I think that
given the time we're not I'm the example
I is I don't have time to do an example
to give you too much intuition for
exactly what these eigenvectors are uh
maybe okay I I can't resist doing a
little bit so we set up a little example
where you have three Goods a computer
and two peripherals and the two
peripherals are complementary to the
computer but independent of each other
in demand and you can set up that little
demand you can set up that little
um
example picking numbers for the
intensities of these complementarities
and you can do the the eigenvector
decomposition you can compute the
eigenvectors of the demand Matrix and
you can see simple so I'll just explain
to you some of what you can read off of
this if you happen to have a cost shock
that raises the price of the peripherals
but simultaneously lowers the price of
the computer that might happen because
of some type of change in commodity
prices that type of cost shock will
transmit one for one into prices so even
though these guys are separate little
monopolists this particular Dimension
this particular cost shock will
translate as if it was a competitive
market if you'd like and then there are
other cost shocks like this last
eigenvector if you had a cost track
proportional to this Vector which is
increasing everyone's costs at some
ratios that cost shock is highly
attenuated the price pass-through is
only a third so if you're this hedge
fund analyst with a theory of exogenous
volatility to costs if you change into
this basis and describe the volatility
to the different eigen opponents of
price then you can say okay if it loads
if the volatility loads mostly onto this
cost axis that's going to be very
transmissive to prices and onto this
other axis it's going to be very much
attenuated by the system and so that's
that's the kind of thing you can do and
um
the example is done in much more detail
in the paper but but let me tell you
about the small tax exercise
yeah absolutely
symmetry
so it's not seeming like you're using
that a lot so if you had heterogeneous
consumers and you just had a
diagonalizable demand function so
Orthodox
yeah but you don't need it we're using
your orthogonality
still have the basis you can still write
yeah but if these basis vectors weren't
orthogonal
I have the feeling that it would really
the reason I the reason I'm not
concerned is because I would just do the
singular value decomposition which gives
you two orthogonal bases one for the
cost one for the prices and everything
would be it would look exactly the same
if they weren't orthogonal I have the
feeling that something would go wrong
but I couldn't but I I believe I believe
you it might not but our solution if we
didn't have a recyclable business is to
do SPD
um but I I should have a sharper answer
to what yeah I think when it's not our
problem the identity doesn't have a
the identity causes some trouble
you can write the identity as you
transpose U which you can take out you
want yeah so we are sort of using that
right we're using the fact that you can
every time you see you you transpose U
that just goes away and that would
that's what would go wrong in the
algebra but
um
you really want to diagonalize I minus B
inverse
yeah that's exactly so if your
technology makes you makes it easy to
pass that through that thing
okay so so tax exercise so how much was
my timekeeper 10 minutes beautiful Okay
so
here is the very stylized tax exercise
that we're going to do okay so we're
going to focus on a little tax
intervention where our planner comes in
planner says look this Market has
inefficiencies in it
and I want to make a little marginal
change to improve matters we're going to
focus on changes that are budget neutral
which means that if you want so the
thing you'd like to do is subsidize
because these guys are under producing
but in order to subsidize some people I
mean I make you make you tax some others
I'm gonna confine myself to to budget
neutral interventions and I'm going to
make the intervention small because
the real reason is that I you know I
don't believe that I understand this
demand system at all away from where we
are and so if I if we're not doing small
interventions then certainly this first
order Theory uh needs to be supplemented
considerably with heavy assumptions on
what's going on elsewhere so let's not
do that
and we're going to give so our we have
two contributions one is a simple micro
Foundation that gives you a completely
specific exercise about a planner who
ends up wanting to do a small
intervention so I'm going to sort of set
that up as an optimization problem and
then characterize the solution which is
what the planner does and the moral of
the story is going to be that the
planner is going to collect revenue from
low welfare pass through eigen bundles
and use that Revenue to subsidize the
production of high welfare pass through
eigen bundles so let me tell you a
little Fable imagine two villages in
this Village all the firms are
competitive so they all Source the same
inputs at a certain cost and they
compete with each other and so price
equals marginal cost in this other
Village
it's a monopoly the firms are all
monopolists uh there's one firm let's
say that's a monopolist and it sells the
same stuff but in a monopoly way what
you'd like to do is collect revenue from
the uh competitive Village and subsidize
the production in the monopolized
village why because the monopolized
village is not producing enough Goods in
the marginal unit that you subsidize the
first unit that that you make because of
the subsidy still very socially valuable
whereas in the competitive Village the
last unit being sold is actually priced
at marginal cost so its social value is
zero and so this is a good this is a
good idea from a welfare perspective the
punch line of this tax exercises that's
what you're going to do in this
entangled complicated oligopoly except
you're not going to do it in this
physically separated way it's going to
be the separation is going to come from
the change of basis that we did
so
um the part of the model uh both whose
cleverness and awkwardness are both due
to Omer so all complaints should go in
that direction uh I I'll tell you the
sort of the the optimization problem we
frame uh in order to make a well-defined
small tax exercise the way we're going
to make taxes small is we're going to
introduce a little uncertainty into what
happens and then we're going to make a
planar risk-averse so a planner is not
going to want to make big changes
because she doesn't like risks and big
changes are going to be associated with
risks so a little more precisely
ultimately
we're going to implement some kind of
taxes on each good the per unit taxes
that are collected you know one dollar
for each unit of production of this good
and maybe subsidize this other good one
dollar but the planner can't set those
taxes exactly instead she chooses Target
taxes and then the actual taxes
implemented are the target tax times uh
Ada which is a random variable with mean
one and some variance so on average she
gets what she wants but there's going to
be this the bureaucracy is going to do
funny things and she doesn't know
exactly how much tax is going to be
collected the reason we do that is
because once that's if she if there's
this feature and she's also risk-averse
then the cost of making a big tax change
is that the perturbations are are also
big and costly and so they might cause a
big welfare loss just due to noisy
implementation so the planner is going
to care about the change this shouldn't
say consumer I mean it's whatever
Surplus you care about but we're doing
total Surplus for this talk so the
planner cares about the change in the
Surplus that she cares about but in a
risk-averse way where she likes it to be
higher in expectation and she doesn't
like uncertainty in it and so that X and
A is how risk-averse she is so now when
we make the plan a risk-averse she's
going to still be trying to do stuff but
in a modest way so she doesn't let this
uncertainty get out of him
and um
so the planner's problem formally is to
choose these Target tax rates in order
to maximize this planner's welfare
function its planner's value subject to
net revenue being zero in expectation
she doesn't have any Revenue to you know
in expectation to spend and so here's
the answer the answer is
that at least when the planner gets
risk-averse enough that's where our
results are sharpest what she's going to
do is she's going to tax each
eigenvector with a pass-through
below some cutoff a welfare pass through
below some cutoff and subsidize each
eigenvector with the welfare pass
through above some cutoff which you can
translate back into eigenvales she's
going to tax the
um
she's going to tax
from up to a certain eigenvalue and then
where tax bundles up to a certain
eigenvalue and subsidize the other
bundle so it's a simple cutoff policy
and the idea is that the revenue
collected is equally good whether it's
from a high welfare pass through or low
welfare pass-through bundle but the
welfare consequences are very different
so that's why it makes sense
um we can characterize the cutoff
explicitly and I don't care so much
about
that but
what what I am what I am happy about is
that we can write in a quite explicit
way the welfare change achieved by this
intervention so
as the planner gets more and more
risk-averse the changes she's going to
make are smaller and smaller so the
welfare change is going to go down but
if we account for that by multiplying
back by this a this risk aversion
parameter I can write explicitly what
the percovian Leverage is so we have
this formula which says that the
perguvian Leverage is n that's the
number of firms divided by this number
and this number just depends on the on
stuff about these welfare pass-throughs
so it's just a list of numbers and you
can look at its mean and it's
cross-sectional variance as a list of
numbers and what I want to emphasize
about it is the Peruvian Leverage is
increasing in the variance of the
welfare pass-throughs so the more spread
apart the welfare passthroughs are the
more the planner can get out of this
little bit of Taxation power another way
to say it is if she has two provinces
she can intervene in this one with a big
dispersion of muse and this one with a
little dispersion and she can only do
one then once her a gets big she'll
choose the one with the big dispersion
because that's where she can do a lot by
taxing the high pass through and
subsidizing the low pass time to start
wrapping up I'm as as you can imagine
there's a lot more to say
I think the only other thing I'll say is
you know you might I don't know that
this is such a problem in this room but
sometimes economists say you're ha you
know it sounds like you're happy about
this kind of characterization but these
eigenvalues and eigenvectors still don't
mean much to me so can you tell me
anything about in terms that that are
not in your Strange eigenvector World
and so there's one thing we we were able
to figure out if we come back from
eigenland into the original basis I can
tell you one finding about this Peruvian
leverage that doesn't require any of
this change of basis and so the result
we have here is that is that this
piguvian leverage which I just told you
about can actually be written in the
original terms okay so the only thing I
need to do use is B the inverse of the
demand Matrix which happens to be the
Hessian of the consumers
um
welfare at the equilibrium and then
pagovian leverage has this form which
isn't the world's nicest formula but it
has a very clear implication so this is
nothing there's no change of basis here
these are just the original you know
entries of the Hessian in the original
basis and the upshot of this formula is
the paguvian Leverage
is depends only on
basically the total magnitude of demand
interactions so the way I want you to
think of this formula is let's take the
curvature of of these Goods in their own
curvature of utility and own Goods to be
fixed what really matters is this sum of
off-diagonal terms of the Hessian
squared and that's saying that what
really matters for the pagovian leverage
for how much the planner can achieve is
the total magnitude of demand
interaction so if I take two systems
which have the same sum of off-diagonal
uh Hessian entries squared and let's say
I change the signs right so I take I
take one hash and then I flip all the
signs then the Peruvian Leverage is not
going to change it doesn't matter
whether they're complications
the complements are substitutes whether
things are compliments or substitutes or
if I rearrange exactly whose complements
are substitutes but I keep that sum the
same right what matters is the sum so
this is like an economic insight and we
have no idea how we would get there
without actually doing the
transformation and coming back okay so
uh I can't I I told you at a high level
about the noisy observation and the
statistics thing we use we get to use
the Davis Kahan theorem to do
approximation approximate recovery of
some of these eigenvectors when we can't
do it exactly and it turns out you can
recover enough to do stuff even when you
observe D with a lot of noise
um but I think what I actually want to
say the only I'll I'll conclude here
sorry
so this is my this is the last slide and
it's my mesoscopic Manifesto
well our mesoscopic I'll implicate my
Co-op so
um there's been there was literature on
this differentiator ligopoly model
people like Vives and um Dixit wrote
down simple versions of this model and
solved it in a case where everybody all
the firms are symmetric with respect to
each other for example
so
I think the status quo is we know how to
fully solve and very explicitly describe
comparative Statics in very simple
symmetric examples and then if you go to
papers like Pellegrino's IO paper we
know how to numerically calibrate
arbitrarily large economies and say
stuff you know purely numerically about
how big is the welfare loss but there's
something to me that's missing in
between which is that you know can you
gain some insight despite the fact that
your economy has 18 firms which are
related in a complicated way can you
kind of think like a physicist and boil
down what's going on to a few sufficient
statistics that you find legible and I
think that
an aspect of network theory that I that
I really like is that you can sometimes
give these kinds of legible statistics
like these eigenvectors and eigenvalues
which apply to medium-sized economies
with a lot of heterogeneity and let you
relate the intuitions of what's going on
in them like somehow I gave these
analogies between separate Villages and
the bundles and that let you use your
intuition about simple examples to think
about this heterogeneous thing and
that's really the value of the kind of
Transformations that we're making so I
think that can generate economic insight
and this is you know uh but this is our
best attempt to substantiate that point
so that's what I had and I would I don't
know if we have time for we don't
okay
maybe one question and then we'll you
know
the amount the amount we tax is
increasing like like it's rank I didn't
say this but we can actually
characterize the magnitude of these
sizes like you the highest task you want
that is the highest welfare Pastor you
want to subsidize the most so you can
you can write it exactly
so at the end of the day
you just convert back from them but you
write it in the new basis and then you
convert back into the old base
[Music]
right you cannot do that but yes you'd
have to ultimately go back
thank you very much